hello and welcome to the show my guest
today is an American writer who
originally came to Europe when he was 2
years old obviously he was too young to
remember that but it must have had some
subliminal effects because he's lived in
many parts of this continent over the
last 4 decades now
Michael letterer currently divides his
time between Dubrovnik where he's the
director of the Shakespeare Festival
there Caracas in northern Spain the
inspiration for his latest novel and
here in Berlin which is his main
domicile welcome to the show that right
is Berlin your main address yes
absolutely and I know that you you were
brought up in California Dubrovnik is
very beautiful I'm told Caracas is
possibly even more beautiful so you tell
us and so why Berlin not known for its
beauty what's so particular about Berlin
no I think that is a writer and somebody
coming from these beautiful places one
can get a bit lost in so many blue skies
and and so many rather you know pleasant
uneventful days and at the end of the
day you don't want to find yourself
writing about you know the flowers
growing and the clouds drifting by and
so you want to you want to be in a place
that that stimulates that doesn't just
rillette relaxed and doesn't just please
so Berlin especially because it was at
the it still is at the epicenter of so
much his
so much dynamic tension the fact that in
the course of a single lifetime you an
older person's life you went from vimar
Republic to National Socialism to a city
and the country divided with a wall to
the wall collapsing now for some years
Germany integrating itself into this new
concept this experiment of a united
Europe and now of course we're adding
one more layer to the story as we see in
Ukraine sort of a real wolken tension
coming I thought when I first came here
that maybe I had missed that that I had
gone from one sort of happy circumstance
to another because in 1998 when I began
to settle here it was really a very
pleasant and very peaceful place and I
wrote the one story Berlin Warsaw
expressed that that even though that may
be a little arrogantly maybe a little
naively expressed some frustration with
that so this history I mean you don't
actually what I've read of yours
I haven't read Canada I haven't read
your latest book but I know roughly what
it's not asked in a second but you don't
write about historical novels that do
but history inspires you very very much
because you what I do write about and I
think most writers of fiction because we
are creating characters we write about
human nature and that expresses itself
in response to stimuli so that's what I
meant by the blue skies and you know
another nice sushi lunch in not enough
stimulation whereas if you subject your
characters and yourself as a writer to
the kind of stimuli that you you find in
a dynamic place like like Berlin I write
about human nature and so you're right
they're not historical
they're not set in in other historic
epics but this is a historic time right
now as well we see that with Ukraine
that's that's just the starkest example
history did not stop as some of us had
had mistakenly thought for a while let's
talk about the the book though cadaques
is your later book is a big tome and is
it this is a picture of life in Caracas
yes that's right mmm these are the this
is me sitting I think two years ago with
a group of friends and these are not
characters in my book Quebecers the
novel but these are people who are
similar in some ways to some to some of
the characters and this was a excuse me
this was the the first full length novel
that I wrote and it's something that I
personally had to get out of my system
because as I've told you off camera
before before we were shooting I spent
too many years of my life drinking and
and smoking marijuana so much so that
thirty five years from the age of 12 to
47 somehow sort of evaporated you know
they went that way that way and
catechize is a place where I used to go
and and and live out some of some of
that story now and there are people
there to this day friends of mine for
instance who were still in that sort of
I'll call it the cha-cha-cha mode so I
went and I and I was very lucky to be
able to set this story about an American
writer who's wrestling with some of
these same issues that I've wrestled
with in the context of this
extraordinary fishing village in Spain I
should mention here actually I mean I it
is next row
a fishing village because I a lot of
artists have lived there I mean I've got
a list here Picasso Marcel Duchamp Dali
and many others actually live there at
one time or other lui boon well garcia
lorca John Cage it's it's a very long
list and what's it what's wonderful is
of course these people have also spent
time in Paris also spent time in New
York mm-hmm but the the soup is a bit
thinner in those big places because
there is also spread out you get an
eensy weensy little village like Caracas
and the ratio of those great 20th
century personalities
to the locals was was big enough so that
the impact they had on the village and
the impact of the village had on them I
mean there was a reason they were they
were drawn to this place and so the
coupling of these great creative
thinkers with these with a very pristine
local context the fishermen for instance
and there and the natural beauty of the
place the rocks that have all these
extraordinary shapes that inspired Dali
and Boone well and others well let's
talk about that character is a bit more
a little later but let's have a look at
how you live here in Berlin now we're
going to get a tour of your neighborhood
together with your wife Katarina but we
begin with a couple of important rooms
in your own home uh-huh
when one writes one sits alone and the
candle of the cigar make me feel a
little less alone as I do it all right
so I'll show you this crazy seven that
we have
this way you was basically for parties I
I inherited this furniture it was not my
style but it's a lot of fun and so we
get this room full of actors and writers
and painters and musicians and there are
some crazy evenings spent here so just
imagine that full of smoke and laughter
and shouting
this is my favorite street in Berlin
this is Bergman strasse in Kreuzberg and
I love it
you've got little lots of cafes little
antiquary arts music shops you buy like
old vinyl book shops
it's very multi-culti which berlin is
and it's a nice it's just a nice
combination of a world capital and at
the same time it's it's a little slower
and easier paced
no book gets written no play no poem
without coffee and so this is the newest
member of our family
Oh
this is already enough reason to move to
Berlin it's the best ice cream on this
planet and probably any planet and we
all become children again when we need
ice cream I think this is one of my
favorite places in Berlin and you get
just real music it's not nothing plastic
a bit from the heart from the soul
this is the nice thing also you run into
friends
see Berlin you could just eat with your
fingers no you can't
Caracas is my guest Michael letterers
latest novel and we've got a signed copy
to give away right to us our address is
in sight at DW de and the novel is set
in Spain in cadaqués of course but parts
of it also take place here in Berlin yes
very important very important part which
you're not going to reveal because
people have to read the book that's
right
but I will I will say one thing that
touches on what we were talking about
before we we went to that little film
that because the you are asking why
Berlin earlier and there's a parallel
because this this book deals with a
character who is trying to reinvent
himself in middle age and take it take a
different Fork and Berlin is is a place
which has done just that if you look at
it in the past you know very few would
have expected it to be this the city
that it is today and so I take great
comfort at a personal level working and
living in the context of a city that has
achieved what I have tried to achieve in
my personal life there's another
connection to Germany and with a picture
we have here which I hope we had a a
close-up of at some point which you just
brought in with us you tell the story
please of this picture yes this is my my
father and his mother his sister and his
father and they my father was born in
Zagreb then Yugoslavia 1929 and his
family was Jewish and after the war
began and the oyster she in Yugoslavia
came rose to power they were forced to
flee my father my grandfather was a
lawyer he was arrested and put into a
camp for practicing law who after it was
forbidden for Jews to practice law my
grandmother Rouge
was the first woman architect in
Yugoslavia they are very comfortable and
very happy life and then as it did for
millions of the war disrupted them they
ran to Italy they they hid for three
years they worked their way down south
eventually to Naples and they were very
very lucky because during the war at
President Roosevelt's behest there was
one single boat on which it was
permitted for a group of Jewish refugees
to come to America
there were 982 on that boat half the
boat were these refugees the other half
were wounded American soldiers from
Anzio and Cassino and they were on that
one boat they run that one Bosa four of
them were were letterers they came to
the States
and they were immediately sent
dispatched to to an internment camp in
Oswego New York but a very a very
pleasant one I mean it was it was a very
nice happy and safe environment and they
had promised they had all signed papers
saying at the end of the war they would
return to Europe well the end of the war
came my grandfather gave congressional
testimony in which he said certainly
will honor our promise to go back but
gentlemen ladies what what are we going
back to so they asked and they received
permission by Truman it was a it was
decree signed by Truman they were
permitted to stay they had to scoot into
Canada literally for an hour turned
around and and come back and so those
982 refugees stayed and that was 1945
and I was America you came to be born in
America I was born in 1956 yeah and we
we move on you were born in the East
Coast but brought up I think in
California mostly am I am I right yes if
you sent you sent in sample wonderful
photos perhaps well yes this this is the
one that I loved the most
this is a view as a two-year-old that
isn't a real cigarette is it it's a it's
an ivory cigarette holder that my father
used for his real cigarettes oh so it
looks like a little pipe sort of thing
but that was in our yard in New Haven
Connecticut and this is I supposed to
the German connection the later hose yes
because while my father's family excuse
me was as I said from Yugoslavia and
Jewish my mother's family was German her
parents both were born in Ch tatin and
German was spoken in their house as as a
variety of languages were spoken in my
father's house so from the beginning I
was born an American and I felt myself
American but I always had one foot here
and here in Europe mm-hmm and that
continues to this day
and the first is sort of conventional
upbringing but then I think things
changed I mean I believe you went to
live presumably with your parents in a
in a into a commune in California no no
no there was not with my parents oh that
was not my father was the last person in
the world who would have done that oh I
see this was this was escape from
parents just yes this was fine to find a
new way with a whole generation that was
finding a new way at the time that's
with my brother Phillip and no was this
when the the the drugs into drink took
no they had already they had already
made their inroads what happened is I
was born in Princeton where my father
was getting his PhD in diplomatic
history and on my first birthday we
moved to New Haven he became a professor
at Yale and we had a really delicious
sort of 1950's style lifestyle you know
father with promising career beautiful
mother
nice yard and friends and then 1965 I
was nine years old and my father
accepted a professorship at Stan
hurt and we jumped into the car this is
in California this is in Palo Alto
California so that's when the the fan
hit the you-know-what and everything
changed and not just for me but for for
the country actually in 1965 was sort of
a Great Divide and when we got to palo
alto my parents almost immediately
divorced my mother became practicing
alcoholic the 1960s were raging around
us and that was like moving moving the
family to Poland in 1939 to go to San
Francisco Bay Area 1965 it was really
going into the eye of the hurricane and
in the context of that puberty I was 12
years old
and so in response to all of that you
know the the drugs were there and the
alcohol was there and and the train left
the track the Michael train got off the
track and it took a very what age were
you then when you went into the commune
so that had begun at 12 the misbehaviour
and the Communist
okay and I kept going back and forth New
York California I lived in Greenwich
Village 1975 and then a girlfriend and I
we moved to this commune in the hills
above Palo Alto that Joan Baez and her
husband David Harris had started is the
Institute for the Study of non-violence
and we lived in a geodesic dome we lived
in a teepee three years without
electricity and I loved her daddy was
not so happy here who should show
picture at this moment of daddy possibly
going off the tracks himself here I
don't know he looks as though he's
having fun he's having a lot of fun he
he he was really sort of above the law
and this is my father dancing in the
home of a dear friend and this is with
my father's partner of many years was
quite a famous actress kitty Carlisle
Hart
and and this was the other side so the
1960s you know I had one foot as a
hippie living in a teepee and then the
other foot a father who lived very
flamboyantly MIGO reliance of no coward
and having Berlin you told me yes well
kiddy both of them knew I mean it was it
was an extraordinary life growing up my
babysitter's as big net Brzezinski
Arthur Okun who later was president
chairman of the President's Council of
Economic Advisers I met Henry Kissinger
and George Kennan these diplomatic
figures through my father from kiddy
which came later you know whether it was
Rex Harris I mean I don't want to drop
names but this was very old world
aesthetics and I and I loved that and I
still do at the same time I was taking
shape as a child of the 60s and so those
two sides were always sort of boom boom
well let's move I want to move back to
Germany because we've got we've got a
report that I think might interest you
because you put in our questionnaire
under dead cool German is record in
other words a German who's not alive
anymore Helmut James Graf on Malta can
now I know he is who he is because I've
done my research but I think most people
will have heard of Stauffenberg sure but
maybe not him tell us a little bit about
him he was an extraordinary figure in
aristocrat who together with a with a
group of like-minded Germans did not
think that National Socialism was the
honorable way in which Germany in the
30s 40s ought to be proceeding on moral
grounds and so he and and and other
others who thought as he did really
began to imagine a Germany
beyond national socialism let's leave it
there because let's find out more about
graf von maka and the so called kaisou
circle part of history I have to say I
didn't know about till that report and
also researching graph on Moscow as your
your favorite German on one of them I
should say you said earlier in the
program that from the age of 12 to 47
you were drunk or stoned
you also said I know in another
interview I really became an expert in
stupid which I thought was very but so
how does it feel to be sober oh it's
it's really a rebirth you know it took a
lot it took a long time addiction is a
horrible thing it gets those fingers
around your throat and to get them to
get them loose is is no easy task I
think there are two million or there
abouts people here in Germany for
instance who who wrestle with this and
for each of them you have you know their
children their parents their friends
their loved ones so a lot of people are
affected and when I was when I was a
younger you know he sort of kept putting
it off and and making excuses and
thinking well this is sort of this is
fun
misunderstanding the kind of damage that
it can do and presumably you were
working during this time I I was an
actor I worked as an actor for many
years and actually I was sort of a
victim of in some in some respects my
own success because I had a variety of
jobs I was director of an art gallery in
New York where I met a very dear friend
who was on your show not very long ago a
Russian artist Sonya chef who's whose
artwork is on the front of the book
absolutely I recognized him recently
yeah wonderful one this way so that led
was a there was a great time and and a
great adventure being
director of an art gallery then I got a
job I was managing editor at Citibank in
New York and I had a big staff and they
paid me a ridiculous amount of money and
I thought you know where is the problem
but of course in a personal level and
I'm sorry to sort of wash clothes in
public but speaking to that what happens
when you are when you have this these
sort of habits is you don't really grow
up you know whenever you're confronted
with with a problem you run and hide in
what you're drinking or what you're
smoking and so when I finally sort of
stepped away from that knock on wood at
at age 47 you know in one respect it was
it was having to begin growing up not
not hiding in these things and was there
a specific moment that made you stop yes
well I mean it was cumulative I wasn't
being the the father that I wanted to be
my son Nicholas was now 26 you know I
was doing my best but it was not my my
best and then I had a wonderful Italian
lady in my life at that time and we were
in the south and Italy and she she said
to me ciao that was enough actually she
worked at the Italian embassy and we
were at the Embassy one night and the
Ambassador who was a wonderful man said
to me I don't want to do my cheesy
Italian accent but um he said to me he
said to me your father was evil Lederer
he was my favorite professor I think at
Yale Stanford oh yeah I have his book on
my table upstairs and I had a glass of
red wine in one hand and I started
slapping him on the shoulder saying I'm
so happy to hear that you know you were
close to my father and really acting
sort of like a cowboy and my friend who
worked at the Embassy came over and said
Michael can you please stop hitting the
ambass
and those sort of moments built up I
mean I fell off of a from the fourth
story of a building in Spain the full
story fourth story of a building at the
time and I rolled a car down the side of
a mountain and there was it was just so
much of that and you the book had a
cares deals with these sorts of things
because you think these are great
stories you know when you're inside it
at the moment you think this is romantic
and this is what poets were supposed to
do or writers actor is supposed to do
and and now if I'm right you haven't
drunk or taking anything for 10 years
tell me briefly about the Dubrovnik
Shakespeare Festival I'm intrigued
because um Shakespeare in Dubrovnik is
it is it in English or well this here
there's a hiatus and we're not exactly
sure whether next year it's going to be
a small festival or more ambitious and
there are reasons for that one is that
having delayed so long the writing I'm
now close to finishing I actually have
finished the the first draft of my next
book that's taken more and more of my
time so I guess so it's not happening at
the moment then the Dubrovnik fest in
breathe in abbreviated form we did we
did a little something in London last
year and in here in Berlin and in
Dubrovnik but it's not the ambitious
scale that it was when it began okay
okay Marlena Dietrich I want to mention
because you put it down as your favorite
singer and I've read your book of short
stories and in there in your short story
alles klar you write about the fact that
berlin women don't wear skirts comparing
them with other european women in
capital city I mean what I say by Lena
Dietrich because she was kind of was she
the first I had androgynous actress I
that I don't know and that I don't think
so I think I think
even even before
but she certainly the one who who
brought the world's attention to to that
let's talk about Berlin women and/or
German women I should say is that you
said that in your short story do you
think that's the case that they I think
that I think Berlin is is distinct from
the rest of Germany and I know it much
better so if you go down south to
mention if you go to Stuttgart or
Frankfurt it's a different pace it's a
different aesthetic and different
priorities I think Berlin the this the
same thing that is a great plus for it
as much of life also has its some some
shortcomings and that's is a very
practical place Berlin which makes it so
comfortable to live here we can depend
we can rely that this is going to
function and and so on and so forth it's
not the most sort of romantic and it
doesn't lean toward excess and then
Berlin doesn't lead to all make sense
well either not of course there except
okay you you are knowing something is
making your smile I just think compared
to the rest it's not excessive no no
anyway there's a square and I know
you're very fond of potsdamer platz will
come to that because there's a square in
building named after Marlena Dietrich
which is part of the new pod stammer
Platz
that's where we're off to right now this
place that holds us historic fascination
for our guests
potsdamer platz slap-bang in the middle
of the city it's a symbol of the new
berlin it's where the old east and west
of the city meet but it's also much more
than that it's a major intersection
surrounded by Berlin's most modern
skyscrapers
at 103 meters the Kohath tower is the
tallest building on potsdamer platz the
office block has a viewing platform on
the 24th floor which offers some of the
finest views over Berlin
directly opposite of the Stoney Center
and dr. Barnes glass-fronted high-rise
offices today's potsdamer platz bears
little resemblance to its form in the
1920s back then it was the undisputed
heart of the city
at what was then Europe's busiest
traffic Junction Berlin's first traffic
lights introduced order to the mayhem
after the wall was built a viewing
platform allowed Westerners to look
across to East Berlin potsdamer platz
became a wasteland after its destruction
in World War two it was located in
no-man's land between east and west
then came the momentous events of
November 1989 when a wall fell
only a few pieces of the wall remained
to remind people of the border that once
divided the city in the mid-1990s
potsdamer platz became Europe's biggest
building site particularly impressive
was the relocation on Rails of the
opulent crisis all a protected historic
remnant of the former Hotel Esplanade it
was in the way of plans new buildings
today the room has been integrated into
the sunny center and restored to its
former glory
it's hired out for exclusive receptions
outside is the sunny center with its
massive canopy the central forum is open
to visitors night and day and is
surrounded by seven buildings including
Sony's European headquarters my guess is
the writer Michael lettera who spends
most of his time in Berlin although he
has a place in Spain and a place in
Dubrovnik as well
what's the particular fascination about
potsdamer platz is it the history again
yes I think I spoke to it earlier when I
said the wreath at Berlin had reinvented
itself and the fact that back in vimar
Germany but stommer Platz was considered
the most modern intersection in Europe
you had the first traffic light in
Europe
you had Columbus house this very modern
architecture of its day then you have
the the war the devastation afterwards
and in many of the buildings even those
not destroyed in the war were destroyed
thereafter and it was a minefield and it
was a visit yeah a no-man's land when I
came to Berlin first 1998 there were so
many building cranes hovering over it
and you could literally see Berlin
reconstructing itself and and today it's
you know it's not everybody's favorite
it might not be my favorite in some ways
but I think it stands as a as a symbol
of Berlin reborn okay the coolest living
German you put down as angular Merkel
and then you put in brackets I can
explain briefly tell us why see your
favorite well I think yeah I I also put
my five-year-old
nephew Lucas I think it was a tie I
think you put him down as the wisest
German though is the wisest remedy about
that was it
angry back it was the coolest German you
know maybe you got those two mixed up I
don't okay so I think he why isn't she
she's very wise she's very wise I think
that in the States of course we elected
twice now no drama
Obama and and there's some comfort you
know thinking that that a leader is not
out just you know to blow whistles and
wave balloons and but but really get get
to work and and I think there's
something that that Europe needs Germany
needs and the world needs in the way
that she very seriously minded mindedly
you know gets gets to work every day
doing doing her best not not extreme to
one way or the other and and there's
just this very comforting one might not
agree of course with everything that she
does but we need we need some little
touch of of quiet to sanity in the
context of today okay you're writing a
new book is that about Berlin tell us
about the new book if you will some
authors don't like to reveal too much no
I'm happy to because this is this is my
I live inside this and it's it's
finished now I'm actually writing a film
script based on it
it's called Don Quixote saving America
and what it is it's the story of a
fellow who we which I was just talking
about the news and which is so
discomforting these days whether it's
Iraq whether it's Ukraine whether it's
global warming we see a lot of things
that we don't really want to see and and
this is a fellow who takes refuge and
watching old television shows from the
50s in which it looks as though
families stay together everyone says
please and thank you mommies and daddies
don't divorce you know
and his his picture of a mayor and
America that he believes was and can be
again and then he sets out in his old
car across the states determined to get
it back to that and of course it's not
it's not as easy as he would like so
there are moments for instance he sees a
little old lady who has just taken some
money from a bank on Mott and she's very
nervously looking around and she's about
to cross the street he gets out of his
old car and he goes up to her to help
her
he says you poor you poor old you know a
poor little thing let me help you and as
he approaches her she starts to scream
help help police thief because she
misinterprets and he says you know I I'm
not I don't want to steal your money
yeah there's a lot of that going on
today there's a lot and so yeah I try I
put in the context of today's very
confused world this man who's trying to
live sort of by the straight and narrow
and and and show that it's not it's not
easy to do and it's my reaction to to
the nerves okay
the best thing about living in Germany I
think might go quite well this god like
you very quickly we've only got about
half a minute left safe center of action
like a bullfight is that how you feel in
Germany yes absolutely and again more so
today because of events just happening
just over our shoulder Hemingway said
once about the bullfight that it's like
having a front seat at the war only you
don't have to dodge the bullets and and
Berlin being being so close to to the
events that are going on near us today
it does feel something like that
although I'm not sure it's as as safe a
distance as some of us would like so
will you stay yes this is home this is
home this is home that's a nice way to
finish it I Culebra thank you it's been
fascinating to meet you thanks thank you
very much for being with us today and
thank you for watching don't forget to
write to us insight at DWD we do like to
hear from you
you could be lucky and be the winner of
this book but also you can write to us
give us your opinions of the show talk
about tell us what you thought of what
Michaels been saying about Berlin
Germany and the world in general or join
us again next week at the same time for
another edition of the show bye bye for
that